um you saw the coach coach brandt oh that was good
news we saw we so my brother hunted down connected
steve not only did we hunt him down we went to the
new wrestling facility oh you're wrestling oh yeah
he gives yeah he unlocked it he unlocked it for
us because the new coach was in vegas with it at
a tournament yeah yeah so he had key like we went
this is a two million dollar facility is your name
still up there by the way can i yeah go ahead go
ahead go ahead i know you guys have talked about
how you used to wrestle poway and stuff yeah steve
is a celebrity there his name is everywhere his
picture is everywhere up on the walls behind glass
cases on plaques what it's amazing is dude yeah
is that real that is real heal steve when you
walk i feel bad for him though cause the window
would wait where were we talking about where
the way he talked about you it's
oh wait don't don't point just
slow down wait wait wait
the way he talked about you
degrading disrespectful demoralizing yeah he
talked about you like you're still in rehab
all right bobby am i lying i got offended on your
behalf right it was the way he talked about it it
was insane all right so let's go dude oh he said
he coulda woulda shoulda he goes he goes bobby
he said bobby graduated from the
school of wood i couldn't show up
oh jesus
he said [Laughter]
all right [__] enough said dude it's crazy
right so coulda woulda shoulda raised and
you know what's the best part what we
caught on camera so you can re-watch it
no we have it on camera yeah yeah we vlogged
everything did you explain to him though
just dude he this is what he said he's like oh
what i heard he does comedy or he's he said it
like it was such a disrespect such a dismission he
was like oh yeah i heard he didn't he was i guess
i guess he's a comedian or something now oh oh
we talked about it for like a half hour in his
car like dude isn't that like he was in his own
microcosm like yeah it made me realize like he
that's his world what was your relationship with
him when you were explain the story ah all right
so in my junior year in high school okay i went
to rehab and went to the mcdonald center okay when
i got what's so [__] funny dude keep going
no no keep going when i got out of the [__]
what the [__] bro i love it this is good all
right so my junior year right so my senior year
i'm sober now okay i had got through the
summer i'd gone to a bunch of meetings and
and me and my sponsor at the time decided because
i had to do so many credits in school to graduate
that he said um my sponsor was just like you you
have to cut weight down to 105 you weigh 125 now
damn i don't think that's a healthy thing i
think we should more focus on the school work
maybe take the year off because you don't
really like wrestling anyway or whatever
so i went to coach brown center i remember vividly
like a coach he's like 105
right we're getting ready
i go i i'm not gonna wrestle this year and he
go he looks at me like this and that's the last
exchange i've ever had with
him oh you're dead to him
[Laughter]
i have your back oh you have my back
yeah there's more to life than wrestling
i know not in his eyes and
that's why he's a winner man
produces champions you know who graduated from
the school would have cut a [__] out with
honors bobby lee yeah yeah didn't tom delonge
graduate from there oh yeah oh yeah yeah but he
didn't graduate from that school he wasn't on the
wrestling team yeah the wrestling team was uh it's
in a prestigious sporting event at our school
it's so nice the new features the new facility
the new facility is like a college like division
one yeah like a real facility like number one oh
they're like nationally ranked yeah yeah it's
crazy they have a slammers program now for kids
they hooked us up you guys yeah we went to yeah
we got these there because steve was there he
let us have whatever we wanted he's like oh yeah
take whatever you want if we would have gone with
you yeah i don't i don't know but yeah you know
bobby you should go wait hold up yeah but this
is the thing you forgot to mention that he was
mad because he was sl slated to wrestle varsity
so that's important you know i was of course i was
going to do a varsity 105 pounder yeah a senior
i know he would would you rather me [__] do
meth and drop the weight and go [__] wrestle
my senior year or did you would you rather me
be sober which which i did fat and sober fat and
sober dude can i ask you this did that technically
the coach can't say that he wants one or the other
but we know which one he wanted he's very very
hollywood of him yeah yeah can i give bobby
yeah give it oh i get one yeah okay my bad oh can
i open it up yeah no i wanted to say this no no
no no what go ahead call me okay i'm not going
to say nothing so this is not a birthday thing
or this no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no just open it up so
open it up i will open it in a second okay but
is this going to hurt me no no it's not going
to rub it this is all about respect dude it's
out of respect it's not going to be a shirt that
says shoulda could have put away the university
oh jeremiah's smiling you're going to get
that merch the new merch at tiger belly
oh wow why'd you get him an xxl
oh baby come here give it to me bob you want to
say a message to the coach yeah bob give branch
to her a message right now please give him
a message dude you gotta dude tell me your
credits man we need to reconciliate tell them your
movie credits man you gotta let the world know man
go ahead man go ahead man that brand said or no
all right man all right i'm okay i'm kind of hurt
all right i'm kind of hurt i think i can get
through it why are you so why are you acting
like that right it's crazy it's crazy right but
can i i'll be honest with you yeah it does burn
and i feel it it burns in my heart damn it's
like a low burn on the bottom half of my heart
and it's probably going to linger there for a
couple of weeks it breaks oh i did the same thing
like the reason why i didn't do well
in school is because if i had a test
i wouldn't do it until that morning study which
sometimes works for some people like i've always
been a very efficient procrastinator were you
did you get good grades in school steve uh
when you were a freshman i was in high school and
we had the same math class oh wow so you were a
senior he was a freshman you're in a class with
your little brother yeah i don't remember yeah we
had the same one yeah one half of the semester so
you're probably still algebra so my brother was in
regular freshman year and i'm in [__] class yeah
like that's you never you just never excelled in
school i'm done even no you're not done but even
in uh junior college you didn't it was yeah your
heart wasn't in it you didn't i would go to a
room he's not good with structure yeah he doesn't
like it we'll go to a room there's a pat lamar
campus it's a community in san marcos they had
these like little rooms that you could just walk
in and there's a piano oh you would play the piano
just play the piano for eight hours you're
just a creative person they say now that the
the rate of graduation has actually gone up
because high school is so much less boring
like there's they you know
they curtail it to more of what
works for a learner like him or a learner like
you not everybody learns the same way right
yeah so they're trying to change the curriculum
to make it kind of more um specific to
one student like you're in science to go you want
to build build a snow castle or whatever they do
yeah you know and then i build one they don't
have subjects anymore so they learn it in like
a more um holistic type of way so i hear that
high school is so much more fun now than when
we were in high school which sucks i [__] yeah
it's like high school was like high school was
like then you'd be in biology class and you don't
understand a word they're saying right and then
you i learned how to sleep with my eyes open no i
did i could fall asleep with my eyes open i can't
and then one time my junior year i was such a bad
kid they had me you know like they had regular
desks but then they had a desk for me with the
walls right so i had i was in the last row but i
had the walls so because they knew i wasn't going
to listen anyway so we just sit there and one time
and then mr what would you i forgot his last
name but he looked he went over the wall he saw
you yeah and i was like this and he didn't say
anything do you watch like he saw he caught me
oh god i mean i guess i've done that
too we had a substitute teacher mr holt
yeah and we were there's a two
parts of the chemistry room there's
where the chairs are at and then there's a
lab behind it and i guess i blew someone well
because he put on a movie he was like the laziest
substitute teacher so he would just kind of like
you blew somebody in class yeah back in the lab in
the middle of the oh class but i really liked him
i really liked him like he was my crush
of all crushes never do that with me
you wouldn't blow me in a [__] class
you take him to a science lab right now
yeah blow him i've blown you in the weirdest
places ever what are you talking about yeah you
have like where are you wait give me give me three
places three places i want to know three because
he here's another thing i used to do though is
when i was on because when i was using i would
ditch class math yeah on math i would ditch class
and i would go to the [__] library of the school
and i would read scientific like books about like
weird sexual [__] and i would jerk off in the
[__] library power yeah who were your friends
in high school like his people did you guys have
different i was a john i was on the wrestling team
and i was a christian i was a part of the students
he was he was i was i was he was not even
you're a christian he was like one of those
like i was like die hard like bible thumper no
yeah take the bible and then paste the [__]
pages on his wall yeah the verses it was like
you know hardcore hardcore did do you still pray
i don't believe in religion anymore when did that
happen for you no maybe yeah maybe in college when
i took acid or something it's something shifted
i'm like this is just yeah this is all [__]
because there's other there's another dimension in
my dorm room and there's dead people this does not
making sense so let's go to an unhelpful advice
uh before that a fan named jay actually sent in
they found all the old yearbooks at poway high
school yeah you were hot dude so that's that's
80 that's 87 yeah and then here's 88 i think your
sophomore year you're on a tennis team they did an
article on you yeah wow which was pretty cool well
that wasn't the article that was the yearbook oh
yeah like when people go um i'm not athletic or
i mean or but what exactly are you doing there
it says bobby backhand it says bobby lee shows his
latest dance moves while on the tennis court yeah
but i was doing this a following through with a
backhand yeah you're pretty i didn't do a double
i didn't do a double hand back hand i could do
a single which is like the fancy one yeah it's
the fancy one you were really a good looking kid
and then this is uh junior year there we go dude
next to the cathedral really good luck yeah
and then senior year oh sweetie how cute yeah
yeah i look like a you started getting a little
fatter that's the turn of the the bus turn banter
okay is that senior year the van you've got to
drive by now it's going a little slower past them
but that that senior year though right yeah it's
from a different school so i'll tell you what
oh mount carmel okay that's mount carmel right
so mount carmel high school and poway high school
right we they they use the same photography um
studio oh remember i told you so what they did was
they saw mine and mount carmel was 60 asian yeah
right and in at poway high it was like three
percent so they just assumed that my photo
was in the wrong section so they send it to
carmel it's cool and that's why i never went
to mount carmel but i'm in the mount carmelo
look up there senior your photos that's you're
joking no that's a true story that's a true story
because look how many asians are on here
that's why they go there's no way that this
guy went to poway that's [__] crazy so
racist that is so racist it's still racist
yeah look we have one two three four five
six on one now go back to now go back to my
junior year uh photo from poway high right
here yeah yeah oh see bobby lee let's see
i can't believe that oh this if they
just send the shoes no but the other
freshman year that uh this one no yeah what each
guy go that one right one girl there's one it just
doesn't seem as asian right right yeah right
go up and down maybe yeah yeah it's all white
people oh white yeah yeah so that's why they made
that assumption and i remember now granted i was
sober so i was in a.a right yeah so i got sober at
the end of my junior year my senior year now i'm
sober right and then the yearbooks come out and
i i'm frantically looking at the senior and now
and then i make a call to the administration and
go um because i remember taking the photo right
let's not let you know if you put a tie on him i
put a tie i did the whole thing right i got i'm
sober i'm going to wear a sweater yeah you know i
mean no that's not yeah go back to the senior one
yeah yeah go back to the senior yeah so keep
working i wear like a vest this and that right
yeah and i'm not in it and i remember calling
my sponsor when they go oh we're so sorry but
your photo was sent to the other high school right
and i remember i can't believe this is my response
i i i think i'm going to relapse yeah because
i did all the things right you know what i mean
he's like come on body it's just your senior year
right now i don't really care about like it did
hurt me back then no that's that's hurtful yeah
it didn't hurt me about that yeah the way that
makes me want to cry because it's like very racist
it's so racial and also there was like only there
was no apology from their end right they were just
telling me the fact well you are asian and they're
you know they were like very like factual about it
right and you know because mount carmel's primary
yeah you know you look like alan laguna
so so yeah so it was like i mean look at it they
i mean they just assumed yeah is that insane
yeah and and poway high school still today
it doesn't look like an american yearbook
this is how she shows up that's how racist they
are yeah they still won't put me in the hot
the power high school walk of fame hall of fame
hall of fame really yeah they have a hall of fame
right no one in there has anything remotely in my
credits right right right one guy played like the
violin in some symphony you know i mean 20 years
ago and it got in to be fair tom delong from blink
182 isn't on there either yeah because tom dolan
went to my school they view my high school views
my kind of fame not real it has to be associated
with you know guy like michael wang like this is
what does he do yeah like this guy he is a part
of the hall of fame yeah he's a doctor he's a
he's a doctor you know that's what they view
right yeah yeah but he is chief of ophthalmology
yeah i did the tonight show at 29. let's go after
five years of doing stand-up that's a big [__]
deal a big deal that's a doctor yeah [__] you
yeah you were on me i didn't eight years uh an
asian guy korean dude on a american sketch show
yes for eight years [__] you that's something
too it's right it's huge it's huge like what
what what the indian girl what's her name
abi ami adoshi what does she do yeah pediatric
hospitalist yeah they're all in the medical field
right you should get a doctorate i should get my
doctor and if they don't [__] put me in a zen
i'll i'll never go you know i think
this is just a part of the larger
theme that comedians don't get respected this may
not be yeah may not be a korean thing like the the
other the yearbook thing was definitely an asian
thing yeah yeah yeah definitely but this could
be just like you know we don't get an oscar we
don't get any respect there's no yeah there's no
award shows we get slapped yeah but now i have
some now okay jensen roof high school but what
else is that's it yeah you won't return his phone
calls okay that's pretty good he's okay okay well
there you go there you go matt you aida uh matt
you ate is also high school but how was he um
what is that who is he is he the other fanny
funniest guy voted for yeah yeah you were
angry about that funniest in high school yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah wait what what is this
there's another asian guy who was voted most
like funniest guy okay i went to powerhouse
and i graduated in 1990 right if you look at
first of all in the 1990 yearbook book of hawaii
high school i'm not in the senior class photos
they took my photo and they sent it to mount
carmel because they used the same photo agency
or place and when they looked at my photo even
though i was in the powy stack they go there's
no way he goes to power high because he's asian
really yeah and they send it because because
mount carmel was 60 50 filipino so they said so my
senior year i never went to mount carmel but my
senior year pictures in mount carmel yearbook
and secondly it's so funny yeah it's
terrible i almost i asked if i could sue but
i was yeah it's you know it's a part of your
memory and then they did that and and then think
about when you find that information out you're
like wait a second so i'm not in our yearbook
and they're like no you're in the other the rival
schools yearbook they're rivals yeah yeah but i
am in a lot of photos so that kind of made up
for it they had like one page with me and my
friend craig dancing at a dance yeah i mean and
an improv me doing improv i want the theater one
so i was fine but um matt ueda is this
japanese dude i went to high school
how come his photo didn't end up in mount carmel
stack because he's more i had like a really like
orange kind of like um tint in my hair and i had
kind of a mullet he looked and i dark yeah it was
dark you were filipino yeah yeah yeah i look like
a oh i see if you look at my instagram way early
on there's a photo that i have super tan where
it's like i look like a um filipino magician
i have a vest on i don't know why i look at that
but anyway um matt you ate a um he's a funny dude
famous now or dude no no he still lives in
poway but um and he i wasn't even nominated
that's the thing when they i found out there
was like nomination there was like five guys
and i kind of asked her okay am i not like no
you're not like i would ask friends you know but
don't you think i should have been knowledgeable
but the people like what was it like theater was
here no i was in theater oh you weren't he was
just more like he was more popular yeah i was
not liked i get that i wasn't in any of those
lists yeah yeah i'm like i'm kind of there's
you know it's you know it's so funny it's you
know you you don't choose where you grow up
your parents do so you're just exposed to these
people i like them and i have fond memories
i know but you know when he won i still think
about it at night yeah i hate those things too
because it is such a popularity contest
most likely to be this yeah i'm not done
hey if they don't accept you what picture did
your you had a your picture end up in the wrong
high schools yearbook maybe you'll end up in their
hall of fame oh yeah yeah so okay all right so i
don't know if you guys know this but my senior
year at poway high school i you know we got our
yearbook at the end of the year there was a mix-up
and they didn't have my photo in the senior year
you know and i went to the administration and i go
um because i was really sensitive about it it was
devastating and i go um my photos what are they
gonna recall they're not gonna they don't give a
[__] and they go oh well uh let's we'll do some
investigating what is george doing there and so
thank you and so that there was a school called
mount carmel that was like all filipinos right
and there was like 40 filipinos that went to that
school super asian because it was in a town called
penisquitus and there's a lot of filipinos that
live in peninsulas i ended up in their yearbook
but it was i i did some research how does that
happen i'll tell you it was the same photography
company and i bet your money they looked at
the pile of powerhouse oh we had a mix up
and they just put my [__] headshot we have space
here yeah yeah and they just put it so i'm in the
penis hold on then we could theoretically nominate
you for both schools and see which one takes you
yeah theoretically yes but you
power high school first because
you know i took classes you know pawi high school
was the school where after i graduated they had a
they were a kid was allowed to go to school
saying that um being gay is a sin right and
you're you know and he wore this shirt around
campus and the administration was okay with it
you know what i mean this is the same so i believe
that they nominate people based on a christian
values value system but it's a public [__]
school right it's not a christian school right
and i could argue in court that i'm more famous
than at least 40 of the people that are on [__]
on that list dude if you took this to court that
would be amazing i might that's how my brother got
me all riled up he got me seeing red man and i'm
going to say this too and i i went to crystalia
i went to whitney cummings i went to every comic
i could and i i made my case you should call
your agent i'm going to call caa yeah i made my
case and i said is this something that i should
make us think about you know what they said all
you said yes you know how we went and had um a
big conference with your um agents and your
reps at caa yeah you should have brought it
up then as a like top priority and it hung up was
your did you lose your virginity to a prostitute
no i um he was 10th in line that was 10th in line
and i'm just going to throw that out baby the way
you said that the way you just [__] said that
you spit in my [__] face i did that was i wanted
to spit in your face she said it very sweetly
[Music] yeah she was almost proud of you i was
the last one in line yeah oh it was it was ten
out of ten okay yeah yeah well it was one girl
she was very progressive whoever that girl was
to think that i want ten in me now dude i wanna
watch that video yeah well this was they were
all in high school so maybe i'm gonna say this
one of the guys in line when i was in my
first rehab so one of the guys in line in
that line i went to rehab and then my friend
from high school visited me at the rehab
and he goes that guy has aids i remember being in
the rehab i'm gonna die from aids i didn't have it
you were 10th new life how did this go down i
know you i don't want i i don't want this girl
because i'm sure she's great and i'm sure she's
a clergy woman everyone you have sex with is a
clergy person okay clergy woman now yeah but um
she was just like this heavier set girl who was
kind of lonely and i was on the wrestling team
and she just kind of had sex with a bunch of guys
how did this go down though was that a party
okay i was with the wrestling team at a party
and she was like just come on over yeah and
we were all in a room good for her and i
just kind of remember waiting in line i got
my leg was that disneyland thursday morning
no fast pass yeah no fast pack also it's like
shouldn't a smaller guy go first because i would
but it went from heavier to small yeah yeah which
is not fair next time reverse it by the time you
got there was she over it was she still no i think
she really because i remember that a couple hours
before that the lights went off in in the party
and she grabbed my head and she made out with me
oh yeah she was into me in a weird way i cannot
believe yeah ten guys yeah so um i don't know
what happened to her and i hope she's doing
great you know sorry about that she's a closer
she's a woman she's with the lord apologize she
she put up something she put up some numbers
it took me 10 years to get 10.
wow she probably wanted to go to college having
you know wanting to say that number how many times
you've been at 10. you're right you're going to be
one just one night yeah you're right you're right
there was a girl in high school that was an
english girl she was a foreign exchange student
and she was really pretty and she was the only
one in high school that wanted to go out with me
but in my head i never she sounded weird her
voice because i just never heard an english
accent before or whatever that that's what threw
me off oh wow that [__] weird yeah that's weird
there were so many moments in my life where
i wish i head back that and also that guy
in nashville that grabbed me at that restaurant so
i went also talking about stevie weebe something
came up and um at first i didn't think it was
a big deal because i've been thinking about it
over you know over the last couple of years and
it doesn't really bother me until my brother so
we're you know i did his show and my brother and
i were hanging out and uh no we were at parks
barbecue and my brother goes yeah man they're
disrespecting you dude you know how steve does it
right who the [__] disrespecting me high school
did your high school was disrespecting you dude
i go you mean the school i went to paw way high he
goes yeah dude you're not on the poway high school
hall of fame and i go i don't care about
that like why would i give a [__]
he goes it's disrespectful dude it's about ethics
see what's right or wrong and stuff like that
and then i started sweating i go you're [__]
right he convinced you yeah it's about the
ethical quality of the situation and he goes
look at it so he will go to power high school's
alumni page and i i honestly i
honestly have tried to be like
sensible about it right to go
okay maybe the people on this list
right are way more famous than me and i get
it because if it had like matthew mcconaughey
right yeah um what's the magician's name david
blaine david blaine yeah right right if they had
anything like that yeah bill clinton he's not a
magician yeah magician builder no no no no bill
clinton that's a good one you know what stop
shaming this one local middle hollywood actor
gabby knows magician that was good so bill
clinton so you go you know i would if those
names were on it i'd be like yeah [__] yeah
i'm a [__] comedian who gives a [__] right
but we googled every [__] name did you really
oh yeah we googled every name on it right and
i couldn't in my head figure out why they got on
to this honorable list and me and tom delong from
blink182 went to my school he's not on it he's not
i'm not on it and what i realize is that the only
people they nominate are people with christian
values what are we doing babe oh no i'm having
some gastrointestinal upset and i think i might
have just um mouth burped oh it's oh it's so good
yeah you heard it yeah yeah yeah i'm so sorry it's
fine babe all right but i'm on a rant right now
all right woman i'm sorry i'm sorry so anyway
we and then he then i started getting rage eyes
when my brother was like see who's
this guy like click on somebody
uh yeah we have uh justin woodruff okay
what does he do from 1996. what do you do
obviously he's one of the most well-known
orthopedic surgeon specialists in
arizona [Laughter] wait and you are who bobby
yeah that's impressive he fixed this human body
yeah but i'm telling you right now is he the
only dude that does that but you fix human hearts
and minds and feet dreamweaver i'm a
dreamweaver all right i create cascades of magic
mentally with my words you know it yeah people
hop on clouds and they live in the netherworld
through my through our joy do you understand what
i'm saying george i could have said it differently
it didn't make any sense what i
said but you get what i'm saying
it hits me in the heart exactly all
right so i'm asking tiger belly listeners
to do a simple thing i think we should get sick
no you can go to the paway high school alumni um
um hall of fame website pawaihyaalumni.org dot org
nominate a candidate you can nominate a candidate
and i want everyone to fill out this form right
i want hundreds of thousands of nominations
for both tom and bobby first me though first
bobby yeah first do me and if you have time
okay no don't put your [__] hand out yeah
can i give you a saving grace can i give you a
saving grace okay before we left he said a lot of
stuff about if you can see and the scissor bros up
yeah but one of the things that i did yeah
before we left because i asked him i said
hey do you have any influence
on the high school hall of fame
and he goes i do know some
people on this he knows the board
so this is what i said this is what i said no just
hear about this fellow brother i thought of this
wait let me just get this straight okay you're
going to be on the shoulder do you want to make
me cry right now no no really yeah because if
you tell me that i'm going to be on the board
and i'm going i'm going to be in the hall of fame
i will start to cry right now the scissor bros is
going to make that happen oh you guys are going
to broker that deal he already emailed him already
emailed him i have a beautiful email with your
list of credits and why you should be considered
yeah we're waiting on a response yeah this
is real this is real though he says he has
influence on the board you are so funny yeah
and you're gonna be in the hall of fame of poway
where okay you know here's where i'm not here
please help me people where where are you it's
all positive news is not even on it well forget
tom it's but as we know with everything else
it's all who you know in that in that field
and he has he's a pillar of the community there
and i asked him i was like is there any way like
okay yes that being said this is the closest we've
gotten i'm just saying it's gonna happen it's
gonna happen i have my response to coach brown
center okay with all the information okay okay
okay think about it think about please think about
it i already just did no really thinking he tells
me to think about it all the time all right now go
okay hold on call him cochi no
voice or reason yeah like hi coaching i'm
not gonna call him okay all right it's me bob
let me just hurry dear kochie it's me bob hi
pretty good um i want to say from the bottom of
my heart i'm sorry that in my senior year that i
chose not to participate in the wrestling program
um i felt like i was focusing on my sobriety and
who i am as a person and trying to figure out
what this whole thing life is but in retrospect
i do apologize i also want to thank you for your
influence right because you're the first
man i've i've seen harry harry knuckles
he had hairy knuckles no honestly i remember as
a kid you remember yeah yeah i remember him like
you know because i'd be like on the bottom like
drink couch yeah and you'll get no you gotta grab
the wrist like this right so you put his hand on
over the other guy's wrist and i would see his
hairy knuckles and i would go i remember thinking
to myself i go i've never seen that before that's
cool right so you're my first hairy knuckle
experience right you're also somebody i was scared
of but i looked up to and i think that you're a
true champion of all time okay and i also want to
say that if you can help me facilitate this hall
of fame situation right that my gratitude will go
so deep towards you and your family and to your
bloodline right we'll have a framed picture of
you and i would fight for your bloodline wow right
and um is that good keep going i love it fantastic
i love it so love dearly love right cochi
i mean heart heart right and putting quotes
bobs
little bobs thank you thank
you so much for doing that yeah
now i want to say something
to you yeah what thank you
thank you so much jeremiah jeremiah
because what you've done okay is you've
created a little monster here what my brother